everybody is familiar with the feeling
that things
are not as they should be that you're
not successful enough
your relationships not satisfying enough
that you don't have the things you crave
a chronic dissatisfaction that makes you
look outwards with envy
and inwards with disappointment pop
culture
advertising and social media make this
worse by reminding you that aiming for
anything less than your dream job is
failure
you need to have great experiences
constantly be conventionally attractive
have a lot of friends and find your
soulmate and that others have all of
these things
and are truly happy and of course a vast
array of self-improvement products
implies that it's all your fault for not
working hard enough on yourself
in the last two decades researchers have
been starting to investigate how we can
counteract these impulses
the field of positive psychology emerged
the study of what makes life worth
living while cognitive behavioral
therapy
was developed to change negative
feelings scientists began to ask
why some people happier and more
satisfied than others
and are there ways to apply what they're
doing right to the rest of us
in this video we want to talk about one
of the strongest predictors of how happy
people are
how easily they make friends and how
good they are at dealing with hardship
an antidote to dissatisfaction so to
speak
gratitude while gratitude may sound like
another self-improvement trend preached
by people who use hashtags
what we currently know about it is based
on a body of scientific work and studies
we'll include them in the description
gratitude can mean
very different things to different
people in different contexts
it's a character trait a feeling a
virtue
and a behavior you can feel grateful
towards someone who did something for
you
for random events like the weather or
even for nature or fate
and it's wired into our biology
how gratitude connects us to each other
the predecessor of gratitude is probably
reciprocity
it likely evolved as a biological signal
that motivates animals to exchange
things for their mutual benefit
and can be found in the animal kingdom
among certain fish
birds or mammals but especially in
primates
when your brain recognizes that
someone's done something nice for you
it reacts with gratitude to motivate you
to repay them
[Music]
this gratitude makes you care about
others and others care about you
this was important because as human
brains got better at reading emotions
selfish individuals were identified and
shunned
it became an evolutionary advantage to
play well with others
and build lasting relationships
for example if you were hungry and
someone else showed you where to find
tasty berries
you felt gratitude towards them and a
bond to return the favor in the future
a drive to be pro-social when you repaid
them
they felt gratitude towards you this
brought your ancestors closer together
and forged bonds and friendships so
early forms of gratitude were biological
mechanisms
that modified your behavior towards
cooperation which helped humans to
dominate earth
but over time gratitude became more than
just an
impulse to play fair the consequences of
gratitude
scientists found that gratitude
stimulates the pathways in your brain
involved in feelings of reward forming
social bonds
and interpreting others intentions it
also makes it easier to save
and retrieve positive memories even more
gratitude directly counteracts negative
feelings and traits
like envy and social comparison
narcissism
cynicism and materialism
as a consequence people who are grateful
no matter what for
tend to be happier and more satisfied
they have better relationships an easier
time making friends
they sleep better tend to suffer less
from depression
addiction and burnout and are better at
dealing with traumatic events
in a way gratitude makes it less likely
that you'll fall into one of the
psychological traps modern life has set
for you
for example gratitude measurably
counters the tendency to forget
and downplay positive events if you work
long and hard for something
actually getting it can feel daft and
empty
you can find yourself emotionally back
where you started and try to achieve the
next biggest thing
looking for that satisfaction instead of
being satisfied with yourself
or imagine being lonely and wanting to
have more friends
you actually might have someone or even
multiple people who want to hang out
but you might feel that this is not
enough that you're a loser
and feel bad about yourself so you might
turn down their attempts to hang out
and become more lonely if you feel
grateful for your relationships instead
you might accept invitations or even
take the initiative
the more often you risk opening up the
higher the chance of solidifying
relationships and meeting new people
in the best case gratitude can trigger a
feedback loop
positive feelings lead to more
pro-social behavior which leads to more
positive social experiences
that cause more positive feelings this
is a common experience after serious
hardship
like chemotherapy for example life can
feel amazing after a crisis is over
the smallest things can be bottomless
sources of joy
from being able to taste to just sitting
in the sun or chatting with a friend
objectively your life is the same or
maybe even slightly worse than before
but your brain compares your present
experiences with the times when life was
bad
and reacts with gratitude so in a
nutshell
gratitude refocuses your attention
towards the good things you have
and the consequences of this shift are
better feelings
and more positive experiences
while it is great to know these things
is there actually a way for you to feel
more of it how to make your brain
more grateful the ability to experience
more or less gratitude is not equally
distributed
you have what's known as trait gratitude
that determines how much you are able to
feel it
it depends on your genetics personality
and culture
this discovery made scientists wonder if
they could design
exercises that change your trait
gratitude and lead to more happiness
let's start with important caveats it's
not yet entirely clear to what degree
gratitude can be trained
or how long the effects last there are
no magic pills for happiness
life is complicated on some days it
feels like you're in control of yourself
and on others you feel like you're not
and this is okay
also sometimes pursuing happiness can
make you more unhappy
if you put too much pressure on yourself
gratitude should also not be seen as a
solution to depression
or a substitute for professional help it
can only be a piece of the puzzle
it's not the solution to the puzzle
itself
the easiest gratitude exercise with the
most solid research behind it
is gratitude journaling it means sitting
down for a few minutes
one to three times a week and writing
down five to ten things you're grateful
for
it might feel weird at first so start
simply
can you feel grateful for a little thing
like how great coffee is
or that someone was kind to you can you
appreciate something someone else did
for you
can you reflect on which things or
people you would miss if they were gone
and be grateful that they're in your
life we're all different
so you'll know what works for you and
that's it really
it feels almost insulting like things
shouldn't be that simple
but in numerous studies the participants
reported more happiness
and a higher general life satisfaction
after doing this practice for a few
weeks
and even more studies have found changes
in brain activity
some months after they ended practicing
gratitude
may be a real way to reprogram yourself
this research shows that your emotions
are not fixed
in the end how you experience life is a
representation of what you believe about
it
if you attack your core beliefs about
yourself and your life
you can change your thoughts and
feelings which automatically changes
your behavior
it's pretty mind-blowing that something
as simple as self-reflection
can hack the pathways in our brain to
fight dissatisfaction
and if this is no reason to be more
optimistic what is
being a human is hard but it doesn't
need to be as hard
and if you actively look you might find
that your life is much better than you
thought
if you're curious and want to try out
gratitude we made a thing
please note that you don't need to buy
anything from anyone to practice
gratitude
all you need is paper a pen and five
minutes
having said that we've made a quote
cutscent gratitude
journal based on studies we've read
conversations with experts
and our personal experiences with
gratitude over the last year
it's structured in a way that might make
it a bit easier to get into the habit of
gratitude journaling
there are short explanations and
reflections to mix it up
and make it more interesting we've also
made it as pretty as we could
this video continues the unofficial
series of more personal
introspective videos from optimistic
nihilism to loneliness and now gratitude
we don't want to be a self-help channel
so we'll keep this sort of video at
roughly one per year
we hope they're helpful to some of you
thank you for watching
[Music]
wait